اعترفت الحكومه الاسرائيليه بان جهاز
المخابرات الداخليه المعروف بالشباب
استخدم قاعده بيانات شركات الاتصالات في
تعقب صحفيين في اطار التحقيقات امنيه
وجنائيه
مقدمه الحكومه على التماس لجمعيه حقوق
المواطن في المحكمه العليا وفق المعلومات
فان بامكان الشباب ان يتعاقب محدثات
هاتفيه لصحفيين ويعرف مدتها والجهه التي
يتصل بها الصحفي وطلب جمعيه حقوق المواطن
بالغاء بند في قانون جهاز المخابرات يلزم
شركات الاتصالات بتزويد الجهاز بمعلومات
عن الاتصالات معينه وقد دفعت الحكومه عن
موقفها باعتبار ان هذا الاجراء مهم في
الحفاظ على امن الدوله واكدت الحكومه وجود
رقابه داخليه على اعطاء المخابرات الاذن
لتعاقب المدرجين ضمن المحافظه سريه ومصدر
المعلومات ومنهم الصحفيون واعضاء الكنيست
والوزراء والمحامون والاطباء